Okay, welcome back to another one of our videos.
This one is all about the risks of oxygen use in the EMS setting.
Specifically, we want to try and answer a few pointed questions.
So first is when should we utilize oxygen?
And then following on from that are two other questions.
When do we need to use 100% oxygen?
And then is there ever a time where we need to give oxygen up to a goal of an SPO2 of
100%?
And then the other general question here is when do we need to withhold oxygen?
Basically we're going to try and answer this question.
Is oxygen the bad guy?
There's a lot of discussion these days about the negative consequences of giving oxygen
to all different kinds of patients.
So we just want to look into that and make sure these aren't false accusations against
our dear friend oxygen.
This next slide just shows the specific adverse effects of oxygen that we're going to talk
about in this presentation.
But just know that that is not an exhaustive list.
There are lots of other things that could be discussed but we focus on the ones that
are most relevant and most often brought up in the EMS setting.
Okay and then just for a little bit of context, this is why we decided to pick this video.
We won't read it all to you but it's all spelled out there for you.
And then just before we get into everything, just know that you're probably not going to
come away from this video, from this presentation with life changing knowledge.
Like everyone at this point pretty much knows that we give oxygen in moderation and that
there are risks associated with giving oxygen in excess.
This is more of a deep dive into the specifics of why that is.
Okay, so the first thing to talk about is oxygen toxicity and free radicals.
So oxygen toxicity is kind of a generic term that we use for damage caused by oxygen.
That said, it's not the O2 molecule itself that is generally the one causing damage.
It's these other forms of oxygen that you can see listed here.
And then of these other species which we can collectively call reactive oxygen species,
some of them are what we call free radicals.
So molecules with a free electron in the outer shell, we're calling back to chemistry class
in high school.
So just to summarize these different terms, oxygen toxicity is damage caused by oxygen
but it's actually caused by these other reactive oxygen species.
And then some of these species such as the superoxide or the hydroxyl radical, those
are free radicals even though we kind of lump them all together sometimes.
And then this next slide is just to point out where these species come from.
So it's not like oxygen is just floating around as an O2 molecule in your blood and it spontaneously
splits into these other forms.
These other forms come up because there are different reactions in your body because you're
exposed to different things in your environments because you have different like pathologic
processes.
So no need to get into the details here but this is just pointing out that there are lots
of different sources of these reactive oxygen species.
And just for a little bit of context, there was some data from years ago that shows that
giving oxygen in high concentration to neonates in a NICU setting resulted in visual impairments.
So this connection of like oxygen causes babies to go blind is why there's a lot of
pushback against giving high concentration oxygen in the healthcare setting in general.
But just recognize that reactive oxygen species are a normal physiologic thing.
They have some benefit in the body and they are important component of a lot of different
reactions.
So they're not all bad.
It's also worth keeping in mind that not all of these reactive species come from giving
oxygen by itself.
We showed a couple sides back there are lots of different sources of these reactive oxygen
species other than high concentration oxygen.
And there's some data that shows that actually giving oxygen can help clear those reactive
oxygen species out of the system when they've been created by some other mechanism.
To summarize it here, yes, damage from too much oxygen is a thing.
And again, we'll talk about some of the specifics here shortly.
But also reactive oxygen species are necessary.
Some oxygen may actually help clear these reactive oxygen species a little bit faster
than if you didn't have any oxygen at all.
So basically just use oxygen in moderation.
Cool.
So the next thing to talk about is alterations in respiratory drive.
And again, this is related to the use of oxygen.
So on the left here is normal.
So the normal stimulus for either breathing or taking more breaths or increasing your
respiratory rate would be an increase in CO2 or carbon dioxide.
Now, if that mechanism fails, you also have a mechanism by which you are triggered to
breathe if you become hypoxic or if you're in a state of acidosis or a stress response,
all of these things.
But normally it follows like in a kind of stepwise process based on like your body's
perceived hierarchy of needs.
The idea with a hypoxic drive, and again, this is an idea, this is not true, but the
idea here was that if you have a patient with a chronic respiratory condition who lives
at baseline with an elevated CO2, that mechanism is not working.
So cross that CO2 stimulus off the list because it doesn't work very well.
So then their primary response to breathe faster or to take a breath or to increase
the respiratory rate is hypoxia.
So the thought, and again, this is not actually how it works, but this is the thought is that
if that were true and then you give these patients oxygen, you take away their respiratory
drive.
So the thought is that giving a chronic lung patient supplemental oxygen would cause them
to stop breathing.
It would take away the respiratory drive and then they would obviously have a bad outcome
because they're not breathing.
In reality, that's not exactly how it works.
There are two other effects at play here and we're going to talk about each one of them
in turn.
So the first one is VQ mismatch and I put in parentheses under their hypoxic pulmonary
vasoconstriction.
So let's just show how that works.
Okay, so real quick here, just for some review, we have two sketches.
Each has an avioli and a corresponding blood supply.
These are both examples of VQ mismatch.
They're just two different flavors.
So on the left is what we call dead space.
So this one we have an avioli that's fully inflated, but not enough blood flow.
So there is air that's getting to that avioli, but not enough corresponding blood supply.
On the right hand side, we have what we call a shunt.
So we have an underinflated avioli and an excess of blood.
Now what the body normally does is in the right hand situation, it knows it's not getting
enough air.
So it vasoconstricts that vessel so that perfusion matches ventilation.
So we call that response hypoxic pulmonary vasoconstriction.
So just to show you in a video that we put from someone else, if you see on the left
hand side here, V equals Q, like there's a match between air flow and blood flow.
On the right hand side in the chronic lung patient, you're not getting enough air flow.
So the body compensates by vasoconstricting that vessel.
So now all the V's match all the Q's and everything is fine.
This is the normal response to the situation.
So that's what the body did to fix the problem.
Now if we were to give oxygen to this patient, we kind of mess with the system a little bit.
So again, we have normal on the left, but on the right we see the patient already compensated
by vasoconstricting, but now we're giving oxygen.
So the body thinks it needs to vasodilate.
The result of that is a reversal of that hypoxic pulmonary vasoconstriction.
And what we get, if you see in the red there, you see an elevated CO2.
So basically we're getting more CO2 dumped into the avioli with no way to actually exhale.
So by giving oxygen to the chronic lung patient, we're increasing their PCO2, which is counter
to what we generally want to be doing.
The other way this happens is via what we call the Haldane effect.
So basically it says that hemoglobin's affinity for CO2 is affected by the amount of oxygen.
So basically in the chronic lung patient, they have an elevated amount of CO2 at baseline.
So some of that CO2 ends up on the hemoglobin.
Now when we give that patient supplemental oxygen, oxygen displaces all of that CO2 into
the bloodstream.
So our arterial concentration of CO2 increases by this other mechanism as well.
So we have two mechanisms.
The first is our VQ mismatch.
When we reverse hypoxic pulmonary vasoconstriction by giving supplemental oxygen, the second
is the Haldane effect where we displace a bunch of CO2 into the bloodstream by giving
oxygen.
So by both of these mechanisms or the combination of the two of them, we can end up in a state
where our PACO2, so our arterial concentration of carbon dioxide, gets really high and that
can in fact lead to decreased level of consciousness and respiratory depression.
So just to summarize this here, we were talking about alterations in respiratory drive due
to oxygen delivery.
This is most frequently discussed in the context of patients with COPD or chronic lung conditions.
So short answer is that no hypoxic drive is not really a thing, but yes, excessive CO2
can cause alterations in respiratory drive.
But that said, it's uncommon, it's a little bit nuanced, and it's not actually due to this
hypoxic drive thing, it's due to other mechanisms.
So moral of the story here, it's totally a-okay to give oxygen to a chronic lung patient.
And then just as with all good things in life, moderation here is key.
Okay, so next on our list of things to discuss is what we call absorption atelectasis.
So here's the idea with this is that if we give someone 100% oxygen, what we do is we
displace all of the nitrogen out of their avioli, so it's just filled with oxygen, right?
Then if we have a portion of the lung or a specific avioli that doesn't have good airflow
to it, let's say we have like mucus or some sort of obstruction, what happens is that
all of the air from the avioli goes into the bloodstream and then the avioli collapses.
You'll have a difference basically of the obstructed avioli collapse all the way, the
other ones work just fine.
So then you end up with atelectasis diffused across the lungs.
So that's the theory.
In reality, it may not be that relevant clinically.
So there were some older studies that kind of looked at this idea and they sort of identified
that it does happen to some degree, but probably not that big of a deal where it affects clinical
outcomes.
And then there's a few more recent studies that kind of found the same thing that yes,
the effect does exist to a degree that can be measured.
But that said, it's mostly in specific cases.
So with no peeps, so we're not manually maintaining those avioli open.
And then also with older patients who, you know, the assumption here is that they also
have multiple comorbidities.
Okay.
So summarize absorption atelectasis.
Yes, it's a thing.
However, the effect is probably exaggerated and may not be clinically relevant.
So totally fine to use oxygen again in moderation.
All right.
Next thing to talk about is impaired cardiac function with the use of supplemental oxygen.
So nowadays we don't routinely give oxygen to patients who are just having chest pain
or we suspect might be having an MI or even if they are having an MI, unless they are
demonstrably hypoxic.
The data on this goes back 50 years or so.
So this paper was written in 1972 and it actually cites prior experiments that kind of showed
the same thing.
So they looked at different hemodynamic parameters using invasive cardiac monitoring and determined
that some of those parameters decrease with use of supplemental oxygen.
Since then, a lot of these experiments have been repeated multiple times.
So this snapshot here is from like a narrative review that talks about a lot of different
studies that have been done about the potential negative consequences of using supplemental
oxygen.
This is just a snapshot of their discussion about cardiac function specifically.
And then two recent trials to mention.
This first one here was done in 2015 and it showed that supplemental oxygen can increase
in FARC size when assessed at six months after an AMI.
And then the second one showed that the use of supplemental oxygen in patients that aren't
known to be hypoxic, so just routinely giving supplemental oxygen increases one year mortality
after an AMI.
And then one last thing to mention about both of these papers is that the authors, again,
in both studies attribute the increase in mortality with the use of supplemental oxygen
to the production of and the effects caused by reactive oxygen species, the same things
that we talked about early in this presentation.
Okay, so let's just summarize this section here.
Yes, impaired cardiac function with supplemental oxygen is a thing.
It occurs via that reactive oxygen species mechanism that we discussed previously.
Yes, the effect can be clinically relevant, but also just keep in mind that profound hypoxia
is not great for cardiac function either.
So you guessed it, use oxygen in moderation.
All right, next thing on our list to discuss is worse outcomes in neurologic injury with
the use of supplemental oxygen.
Now neurologic injury includes both stroke and traumatic brain injury.
And the idea is that those reactive oxygen species that we've been talking about all
along, they can cause further injury, worse outcomes, or secondary damage in either one
of these cases, either stroke or traumatic brain injury.
Now that said, it does get a little bit more complicated than that.
So we know that hypoxia results in worse outcomes for patients.
So there's studies both for stroke and for TBI that demonstrate this fairly clearly.
That said, there's also the idea that hyperoxia, so too much oxygen, can result in decreased
cerebral blood flow.
Now, the mechanism is not super well understood.
It could be related to those reactive oxygen species that we just showed.
It also could be correlated with vasoconstriction and vasodilation related to arterial CO2.
So that's what these images here show.
So basically as your CO2 increases, then your cerebral blood flow also increases.
And then you have an inverse relationship with oxygen.
As your O2 increases in your arterial blood, then you get a decrease in cerebral blood
flow because your body thinks that it already has enough.
So that's another proposed mechanism.
So again, not super clear there, but by either one of these ways, it is known that hyperoxia
or too much oxygen can decrease cerebral blood flow.
So moving on with that idea, hyperoxia is when we have too much oxygen in the bloodstream.
So with stroke, we do see decrease in blood flow.
So that has been demonstrated.
That said, we also do see some neuroprotection.
And the mechanism here is by reducing inflammation.
Now, we have a similar sort of conundrum with traumatic brain injury.
We already talked about how the reactive oxygen species can cause damage, but we also
know that giving oxygen can improve outcomes if it's done early after a TBI.
And there's another study more recently that shows that it doesn't actually worsen outcomes.
So we have a little bit of a complicated picture on this one.
And you'll see that in just a couple of slides, we show a summary chart that kind of outlines
when we should and shouldn't give oxygen.
And the general consensus these days is that in stroke, you withhold oxygen unless somebody
is hypoxic.
In TBI, it's a little bit more acceptable to give oxygen.
That said, this neuroprotection with administration of supplements oxygen for stroke patients,
it has been demonstrated, but it hasn't really changed, practiced or entered into how we
do things yet.
Another paper to mention is this one from the Journal of Cerebral Blood Flow and Metabolism.
So arguably the people who ought to know the most about this subject in general.
So basically, they wanted to investigate this idea of cerebral blood flow and oxygen utilization
in the brain based on FiO2.
They used a novel technique to measure oxygen metabolism in the brain.
So basically they found that in the hyperoxic states, the metabolism is decreased and in
hypoxic states, it's increased.
So same trend we sometimes see with measures of cerebral blood flow.
In a hypoxic state, we increase it.
And in a hyperoxic state, or when we give supplemental oxygen, we actually see a decrease
in cerebral blood flow.
Let's summarize here regarding worse outcomes in neurologic injury.
Yes, hyperoxia can worsen outcomes, but also yes, hypoxia can worsen outcomes.
Hyperoxia, so too much oxygen, can be neuroprotective, but it can also cause damage.
So the moral here is that there are many, many factors at play, both with stroke and
in traumatic brain injury.
But just like with all the other points, the moral here is that use oxygen in moderation.
All right, quick recap.
These are the five potential adverse effects of oxygen that we already discussed.
Now let's move on to some of the specifics.
So first is indications, like when should we use oxygen?
This chart here is just taken from a paper.
Feel free to follow the link to check that out.
But we've just drawn arrows pointing to the things that are specific to us in the EMS
setting.
So we won't go through all of these points, but just know that the things in green are
ones where it's totally fine to give oxygen per this chart, things in red, contraindicated,
and then there's some nuance with the yellow ones.
Again, feel free to pause the video, zoom in, take a look at some of the stuff we've
already discussed and some of it we'll get to here in just a second.
So that's indications.
There are also some contraindications.
This list here is from a website called deranged physiology.
I think we cited it once before.
It's one of our favorite places on the internet.
But this basically is a list of when we might want to hold off on giving oxygen.
And we've made a couple of annotations here based on, again, things we've already discussed
and things that we'll discuss in just a second.
All right.
So situations in which giving 100% or pure oxygen is okay.
So first is if we have a true bona fide hypoxia.
So find to give oxygen.
Carbon monoxide exposure, also fine.
Dramatic brain injury, we already talked about.
Or it depends, but in general, could be okay.
Prolonged CPR, also fine.
Pre-oxygenation, for example, in anticipation of a procedure or RSI or intubation, totally
fine.
The next two require just a little bit of explanation.
So the first one is decompression illness.
So with these patients, we do want to give oxygen, but just know that we're not just
giving oxygen to ensure oxygen delivery to the tissues.
There's other reasons.
And you can read more about that in the article cited here.
The next one is something that I came across while I was putting this video together.
And this is denitrogenation of air-filled cavities.
So that sounds a little complicated.
But basically, if you have a situation where there's like a pocket of air in the body that's
causing problems, so for example, a pneumothorax, if you fill that cavity with oxygen, so instead
of just regular air, which is mostly nitrogen, but if you slowly get that cavity all the
way full of oxygen, that oxygen will then make its way into the bloodstream and it could
potentially reduce the size of that cavity.
And then a few cases here to point out where we often here discuss that we should give
oxygen, but in reality, the risk of damage from reactive oxygen species may actually
outweigh the benefit.
So we won't talk about these in depth, but there are articles linked for each one of
them.
The three of these are altitude illness, intrauterine resuscitation, and sepsis.
So in all of these cases, it is often taught to give 100% oxygen, but that may actually
cause more damage.
Okay, next thing to mention is that sometimes it is fine to give oxygen in high flow up
to an SPO2 of 100% and maintain that.
So the two reasons we would want to do that would be carbon monoxide exposure or decompression
illness, and then there's potentially a use case for those airfield problems that we just
discussed.
Let's just summarize here on 100% oxygen.
So 100% oxygen delivery is okay until our SPO2 gets into a therapeutic range.
So for example, over 90%.
That said, continuing to give oxygen to maintain an SPO2 of 100% generally is not needed in
except in a few specific use cases.
Okay, one final point to make and then we'll wrap everything up.
We want to know at what dose of oxygen are we even concerned about producing reactive
oxygen species?
We already mentioned that these are the problematic things in this whole process, but how do we
know what is a safe dose of oxygen?
The answer to that question is a little bit elusive, and the reason for that is because
it's a function of intracellular partial pressure of oxygen.
So you can see on this chart that at the low end, so when we're hypoxic intracellularly,
we have a spike in the production of reactive oxygen species, and then at the high end,
when we're hyperoxic inside the cells, we see an exponential increase in the production
of these reactive oxygen species.
But those numbers, those intracellular PO2 numbers don't correlate cleanly with an arterial
partial pressure of oxygen.
That said, based on the data we had that looks at complications from the use of supplemental
oxygen, we can kind of assume that if we have a PO2 of 100 millimeters of mercury or less,
we're probably fine.
And then once we get up to 300 or so, that's when we start to see a lot of issues.
That's when we see an increase in damage caused by these reactive oxygen species.
So to put some numbers to that, if we have a patient on, let's say, two liters per minute
of oxygen via nasal cannula or an FI2 of about 30%, this correlates with a PAO2 of
around 100, and that's probably fine in most cases.
On the extreme end, once we get to a PAO2 of 300 or more, we definitely have damage.
We definitely have an increase in the production of reactive oxygen species.
That would correlate with an FI2 of about 60 or maybe giving oxygen via a non-rebreather
mask.
So when we're using oxygen at that dose, we ought to have some concern, especially
if we're beyond the point where we fixed a low SPO2.
And then there's also a time component.
So we also want to know how long does it take when we're giving supplemental oxygen for
the reactive oxygen species to be produced and then to cause damage.
Again, there's not a really straightforward answer here, but when we're giving 100% or
high flow oxygen, normally within five to 20 minutes, our PAO2, our arterial partial
pressure of oxygen plateaus based on whatever FIO2 we're delivering.
And then we can assume that in that same timeframe, our intracellular oxygen concentration also
reaches the plateau.
With low flow delivery, the timeline is the same.
Just recognize that we may not ever reach an intracellular oxygen concentration that
results in the production of reactive oxygen species.
Okay, let's end with just a quick review.
So this is what we started with.
These are the questions that we wanted to answer.
So let's just put them all together with answers on one slide.
So when should we utilize oxygen?
In general, when our SPO2 is below goal or we have some other evidence of hypoxia.
And then what about 100% oxygen?
So we talked about these cases would be hypoxia, carbon monoxide, traumatic brain injury, CPR,
peroxogenation, decompression illness, or airfield issues.
And then what about when do we want an SPO2 of 100%?
So again, those are carbon monoxide exposure, decompression illness, and then maybe those
airfield issues.
And then when should we withhold oxygen?
So in general, once SPO2 is in range, we should start to titrate down.
So oftentimes this is somewhere between 90 and 93, depending on what agency you work
for.
All right, so is oxygen the bad guy?
Probably not at low flows, and then it depends at high flow.
That's it.
That's all we got.